president Trump has won the Iowa
caucuses this is the first match for the
2024 presidential primary the first
votes that are actually cast and he
didn't just win it by a little he won it
by a lot he won with more than 50% of
the vote which means that even if all of
the other candidates had Consolidated
and worked together and and endorsed one
anti-trump candidat still Trump would
have won the caucuses now in his victory
Free Speech president Trump did not take
pot shots and attack people and insult
everyone he actually was pretty gracious
and congratulated his
competitors I want to congratulate Ron
and Nikki for having a a good a good
time together we're all having a good
time
together and uh I think they both
actually did very well I really do I
think they both did very well we don't
even know what the outcome of second
place is and uh I see G Lake
congratulations
Carrie I spotted her I have to announce
because she's terrific GNA be a senator
great Senator I predict right you're
going to be a great Senator and uh I
also want to congratulate VI because he
did a hell of a job he came from uh zero
and he's got a big percent probably 8%
almost 8% and that's a an amazing job
they all did they're all very smart very
smart people very capable people some
consider this to be uncharacteristic for
Trump but I I don't think that's the
case at all we've seen this from Trump
forever he's brutal when you go
head-to-head with him and then he's
generally pretty gracious in Victory he
says oh yeah I called lion Ted the worst
most terrible man in the world and I
said that his dad killed Kennedy but
that was then this is now now I think
he's beautiful no big deal and that's
the tact he's taking here uh he mentions
V ramaswami of a for his part after the
caucuses drops out of the campaign and
makes a big
announcement as of this moment we are
going to suspend this presidential
campaign and this is going to have to
be there is no path for me to be the
next president absent things that we
don't want to see happen in this country
and I'm also making the decision that
this has to be an America First
candidate in that white house as I've
said since the beginning there are two
America First candidates in this race
and earlier tonight I called Donald
Trump to tell him that I congratulate
him on his victory and now going forward
he will have my full endorsement for the
presidency and I think we're going to do
the right thing for this country so a
drops out endorses
Trump I think the smart move for him and
people are saying well you know he he
should have done better in Iowa he could
have won Iowa I don't know no one had
ever heard of this guy a year ago and
then his first time ever running for
public office he runs for president he
ends up in the final four presidential
candidates and he pulls 7.7% it's pretty
good never held office does better than
a whole lot of other people who had much
more political experience so V clearly
has a bright future in front of him the
question now is what happens to DeSantis
and Haley DeSantis pulled out the second
place finish he was only a point or two
above Haley uh neck and neck but Des
Santa still gets number two he still
seems to me to be the hardest hit
candidate in this race
because what last night proved is that
the polls were right the polls were
almost dead on the money about how it
was going to shake out in
Iowa and if the polls are right then the
DeSantis Campa cign is
over we've been in a whole lot of
nothing for about 18 months now just
chatter and talk and tweets and TV
commercials and this is the first time
any votes were cast and Things Can
Happen gradually and then suddenly in
politics we are now in the suddenly
phase pretty soon this whole primary
could be over frankly in a matter of
days I'm Michael nolles this is the
Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the show the CEO of
United Airlines who is reportedly a drag
queen is foisting Dei into the cockpit
I'm sure that will make you feel much
safer when you travel we'll get to that
in just a moment first though the
campaigns what happens
here Trump wins Iowa as far as I'm
concerned the primary is over
now the V is out that leaves Dan santis
and
Haley Haley might have an argument to
keep running and the reason for that is
even though Trump is dominating in all
of the primaries all of the upcoming
primaries you've got New Hampshire
you've got South Carolina you've got
Nevada you've got Michigan Trump is
up double digits everywhere uh but there
might be an argument for haey to hang on
because Trump is only up 10 to 13 points
in New Hampshire and Haley is the second
place candidate so if she has a nice
showing there or maybe if she has even a
surprise Victory then that might get her
to keep going along until South Carolina
which is her home state Trump is up by
much more actually in South Carolina but
she could she could keep trying to Duke
this thing out uh Dan santis has a much
harder time because next up you have New
Hampshire and in New Hampshire he's
currently in fourth place he's got
something like 6 and a half% there
Haley's pulling at 20% plus uh it could
be a brutal defeat and then you go on
and he's not looking good in South
Carolina and he's not looking good in
Nevada and he's not looking good in
Michigan and and eventually if if Dan
santis is not going to get the
nomination he's got to get out before
Florida cuz right now in desantis's home
state where he is currently the governor
Trump is up 40 points in Florida so if
he sticks in that long he could be
headed for a humiliating defeat and to
save his political career I think he
would have to get out before that happen
so Haley's got a little bit more time to
play with even even if it's a complete
long shot for her in the race uh she
doesn't have a a pressing deadline like
that she's still pulling well enough in
South Carolina that I I think maybe she
can hang on she's not a sitting Governor
right now for it's a little bit tougher
uh I think Mike Lee the Republican
libertarian senator from Utah made a a a
pretty good argument as to how absent a
lightning strike whether it be from the
sky or from the Democrats Trump is the
nominee look whether you like Donald
Trump or not whether you agree with
everything he says or not he is our one
opportunity to choose order over chaos
and putting America First Over America
last it's time to get behind him and
look in presidential campaigns there are
always a lot of promises made my
favorite kinds of political promises are
Promises Kept Donald Trump has kept
promises that he's made as he's
campaigned in the past we know what kind
of President he will be and so whether
you agree with him on every point or not
if you are not content with the status
quo the status quo of lawlessness of
putting America last it's time to get
behind Donald Trump and I wholeheartedly
endorse Donald J Trump in his bid for
the presidency in
2024 clear enough and it hearkens back
to a political Maxim first put out there
by Otto von bismar which is that
politics is the art of the possible the
art of the
attainable the art of the next best and
there are going to be people who don't
love Trump or who liked him in 2016 or
2020 but don't like him any anymore they
think this guy would be better or that
guy would be better or whatever but what
Mike Lee is saying here
is there's clearly one candidate who can
in any way unify the GOP there's one guy
who has proved himself to be Far and
Away clearly the leader of the pack and
he's the guy and maybe you prefer
another guy and maybe you wish that he
weren't but he just is the guy and so
we've got to put the interessi and
squabbles side we've got to quit burning
GOP money when there is no path to
Victory really for any of the other
candidates and we just need to be a team
player wasn't that the point of the
Pledge before the GOP debate The Pledge
was you need to agree to support the
eventual nominee and everyone but Trump
signed it Trump said I'm not going to
sign that because I don't really believe
it and I'm not I'm I'm not going to
promise something that I'm not going to
deliver on and the other candidates
signed it and then Chris Christie the
first big one to drop out of the race I
actually didn't mean that as a pun but
there you have it he drops out and then
he says I'm not going to support Trump
oh so you're a liar so you you're you're
just the thing that you accuse Trump of
being but Lee is saying look Trump was
good maybe you wish he did more or he
did things differently but he was a good
president he did more for conservatives
than a lot of other Republicans have and
anyway he's the guy now so I'm going to
get behind him and you should too that's
his argument and it's a fairly
persuasive argument it might not be the
most idealistically satisfying but it is
what it is man this is the way the race
has shaken out all right now Donald
Trump we're familiar with him he's put
his name in Gold Everywhere for 40 years
and when you want to focus on gold you
got to check out Birch gold right now
text nolles to 98 9898 as we head toward
a presidential election in November
there's one thing you can be sure of
2024 will be a tumultuous year how will
your hard-earned savings fa you already
see the impacts of inflation at the pump
and the grocery store the dollar
continues to lose buying power faster
than wages can increase how are you
protecting your savings consider
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
for decades gold has been the choice for
investors and central banks to hedge
against inflation if you have an IRA or
401K from a previous employer that is
just Gathering dust call Birch gold and
they will help you convert it into an
IRA in Gold you won't pay a penny out of
pocket Birch gold will simply convert
that 401k into physical gold which
unlike digital currency can't be
tampered with just text Nes K wle to 98
9898 and Birch gold will send you a free
info kit today Birch gold has an A+
rating with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of satisfied customers they
have been the exclusive gold company of
the daily wire for the past seven years
we trust them you can trust them too
text Nes to 998 9898 claim your free
info kit that is nles to 98 9898 to
secure your savings now the post-mortems
are already
starting for the other GOP campaigns in
particular the danis campaign because
Iowa is where they staked the
campaign Ronda santis himself is
beginning to indulge these excuses the
big new one of late is that the failure
of The disantis Campaign lies with the
conservative
media he's got basically a petorian
guard of of of the conservative Media
Fox News um you know the the websites
all the the stuff they just don't they
don't hold them accountable because
they're worried about losing viewers and
they don't want to have the ratings go
down uh and that's just that's just the
reality that's just the truth and I'm
not complaining about it um I'd rather
that not be the case but that's just I
think an objective reality this is not a
good look for Ronda
santis in park is it just isn't
true if Governor Dan santis here is
arguing that the conservative media were
just always totally behind Trump and
they didn't give him a fair shake and
that's why his campaign never took off
that is ridiculous Fox boosted him in
the early days of his campaign plenty of
people over at the blaze boosted
DeSantis in the early days of the
campaign most of the hosts at the daily
wire explicitly endorsed Ronda santz I
did not I did not endorse any candidate
I said as a matter of principle I I
don't think that's my role in the race
and I'd rather make observ and
predictions I'm not here to work for any
campaign so I'm I'm going to stay out of
it but most of my colleagues when asked
who would you vote for for president
they said
disantis so sure over time maybe some of
the coverage changed on Fox or wherever
but he actually did have a lot of
support from the conservative
media then he says that the conservative
media chose ratings over you know the
interests of GOP voters or something but
what does that even mean in this case
you're talking about the conservative
media if we're talking about the
conservative media then ratings is
directly related to the desires of GOP
voters it's I'm not saying it's exactly
a oneto one but it's pretty close so
even if there were people in the in the
media who were just shifting their their
agulation of disantis based on the poll
numbers based on ratings rather that
would relate to the poll numbers it
would relate to the vote what do I think
is really going on on here people are
going to say DeSantis was a bad
candidate I don't think that's
true people are going to say the
disantis campaign was run poorly I don't
think that's true sure he as a candidate
had flaws and the campaign made some
mistakes without question but I think
the campaign was basically fine and I
think Dan santis is an excellent
Governor I really like the guy I think
in any other race he would have been
clearing away a leader if not the top
guy in the whole race from the beginning
I blame circumstance here which is what
I've said from day one of this primary
which is that DeSantis had an impossible
task the biggest appeal of Ronda santis
as a candidate the initial pitch of his
campaign is that he was Trump without
the baggage he's all the good stuff
about Trump that you like the the
effective policies the irritating the
left the uh more Hands-On approach the
the greater willingness to wield
political power uh rather than uh
keeping the gloves off and and just
spouting off libertarian platitudes uh
you know he's the guy who's going to
he's going to be rough and tumble with
the universities he's going to fight
Disney and he's going to reopen the
country he's going to reopen his State
at least during covid something that he
said Donald Trump didn't even do that I
I I was much better on Co than Donald
Trump I'm Trump without the baggage I'm
bigger better faster stronger okay that
was the pitch but his role in the race
was to not be Donald Trump his role in
the race was to be the anti-trump
candidate and
so he he seems like he could have been
the best candidate but actually what
that meant politically is that he was a
man without a home because the people
who like Trump were going to go with
Trump and the people who don't like
Trump wouldn't want anyone who in any
way resembles
Trump and and Governor DeSantis has this
problem where he just isn't Trump trump
is running in the race and he is not him
and he is kind of like Trump he actually
is kind of like the Trump without the
baggage they have some differences on
policy but they're cut from the same
cloth they belong to the same part of
the party they share a constituency and
the constituency was not willing to
abandon Trump to go over to him and he
couldn't pull enough of the other guys
the other guys the The Establishment
side the neoconservative side the bush
side they're going over to Nikki Haley
right now and and so what was he going
to do what was he going to do was he
going to sit out this race no I don't
think that would have been a good move
either because had he waited until 2028
everyone would have forgotten about him
it would have been Chris Christie all
over again I suspect the reason that
DeSantis ran this time is because he
learned the lesson of Chris chrisy 2012
it's hard to remember now because
Christie is a punchline Chris Christie
was the man Chris Christie was the most
popular Republican governor in the
country he could have run for president
he might have gotten the nomination but
he waited until 2016 and in 2016 he was
an afterthought and then he ran again in
2024 and he was a punch line so DeSantis
didn't want that to
happen DeSantis is going to leave office
in early January of 2027 that's almost
two years before election day 20128
people would have forgotten about him
they would have forgotten about his big
political wins they've already forgotten
about his big political wins DeSantis
really came to the stage during covid it
it was amazing he showed incredible
courage and incredible vision during Co
and people don't even remember it they
don't care about it anymore political
memory is relatively short issues
change and and
so it's
tragic it it's I mean that in like Greek
tragedy sense the greatest strength of
the disantis campaign was its
weakness and and
circumstances forced this to come out he
didn't have a better Avenue available to
to him the reason he was popular was
because he was kind of like Trump but he
was still kind of clubbable with some of
the establishment types but that was his
undoing the the time he was going to run
was going to be now but it was a it was
a once in a century moment when an
incumbent when a former president was
running for a non-consecutive second
term effectively as an incumbent which
is how the voters clearly are treating
him
there's no one to blame there's no one
to blame it's just circumstance and
that's probably the least satisfying
answer for supporters of a losing
campaign now there might still be an
argument for Nikki to run or to to keep
in the race because she has less
pressure to drop out uh but she's saying
all sorts of things that are really
irritating conservatives Nikki just two
days ago came out and refused to say
that a man cannot become a woman this is
a transcript from uh Megan Kelly
U Nikki was asked um let's get to our
last question uh this is from John who
uh has a question for you Ambassador hi
John John says a lot of the stuff that
Trump does you know and says really
bothers me and I'm concerned about it
you know one thing I saw him do was he
said that uh he had trouble answering
the question could a man become a woman
I'm just wondering what your response is
and then this is the response I'm not
going to read the whole thing it's so
long but Nikki says yeah I mean I think
first of all let's look at the facts
again I'm sorry we didn't we didn't make
it out to your part of the state I hate
that we're not there but I appreciate
you coming here look I mean I've said I
want to start with Trump and then get to
the question you know this is a hard
truth on my part I believe Trump was the
right president at the right time and so
then she goes into the whole thing about
I I I liked Trump that's why I worked
for him but he's not the right guy now
and I'm the right guy so she goes into
that whole thing and then after a
paragraph she goes now can a man become
a woman there's been a lot that's been
been talked about when it comes to all
these roles and all these issues I
strongly believe that we should not
allow any gender change surgeries to
anyone before the age of 18 period we
kids now can't get a tattoo until
they're 18 we shouldn't have them
permanently change their body until
they're 18 and that includes puberty
blockers after the age of 18 we want to
make sure that people can live any way
they want to live I don't think
government needs to be in control of
anybody's life you can live the way you
want to live and you should be free to
live the way you want to live and every
government and everybody else should
stay out of your way but prior to 18 you
know that's bad okay uh this is not my
view my view is that for the good of
society and especially for the good of
the poor people Afflicted with this
confusion the whole Preposterous
ideology at every level that's not
Nikki's view Nikki's view is that we
should stop but we should indulge at
least to some degree for adults and so
it's not my view but that is the view of
a lot of people and that is the view of
a lot of Republican voters that is the
view of a lot of self-styled
right-wingers and importantly that is
the view look I think that actually is
her personal view I don't think she's
being dishonest or anything here but
more importantly from a political
perspective that is the view that fits
her Lane in the race her Lane is the
consiliary Centrist kind of
establishment kind of neocon Lane it's
the anti-trump lane it's going to win
over all those Suburban housewives that
hate Trump at least according to the
posters that's a view that's a that's a
big view in the party and if you're
going to compete you got to you got to
know your lane you've got to you've got
to see a path to Victory there so she
might lose she might go around state
byst state and get 20% of the vote in
every state and Trump gets 80% of the
vote and then he becomes the nominee and
she's the number two person and maybe
there's a Unity ticket or maybe she gets
a position in the cabinet or maybe she
increases her leverage or who knows
maybe they throw Trump in jail or worse
and Nikki is the last person standing
and she gets the nomination there's
there's an argument for her to stay in
the race
but the only way she's going to stay in
the race is is by continuing to irritate
the right winger she's going to have to
move even more to the center maybe even
a little to the center left on an issue
like this this is an issue where
Democrats of 10 years ago would never
have said yeah people have a right to
men have a right to use the women's
bathroom as long as they're
adults but but the country's moved to
the left on that issue on a lot of
social issues so that's where she is
she's finding that space in the
Center and it it shows a split in the
party too because I think especially
among Boomers and Gen X that's a that's
a really acceptable answer among Zoomers
that's not an acceptable answer the
Zoomers strike me and I meet a lot of
them and I travel all over the country
they strike me as much more socially
conservative the GOP Zoomers and
Millennials are a little bit split
that's a generational divide but she's
picked her side of it
and it might take her pretty far if she
sticks in the race
now Trump obviously comes out looking
pretty good from Iowa when you want to
look good you got to check out Jus cell
right now go to genucell.com
this year make a resolution that is easy
to keep and delivers immediately on its
promise with genus cell skincare you can
turn back the clock and look 5 10 or
even 15 years younger right now genus
cell skincare is celebrating 20124 with
its New Year's Sales Event you will save
over 70% off all your geny must haves in
their most popular package say goodbye
to Fine Lines forehead wrinkles sagging
jaw lines dark marks skin redness and
even under eye bags leave them in 2023
genus cell works for women and men it's
safe for all skin types and is perfect
for skin of any age plus genus cell
promises immediate results that will
make you smile guaranteed or 100% of
your money back right now for a limited
time jenus cell's top selling hyaluronic
acid Serum is included free in every
most popular package I love this company
I really love the products even I have
used them I like to say I just woke up
like this and I don't use any but you
know even I have used them they're
really great products uh people in our
office love them the founder is a Coptic
Christian from Egypt left for the
American dream and they use only the top
ingredients enjoy maximum skin hydration
for a more youthful look Janus cell.com
noes enter code NES for extra savings to
checkout every order automatically
upgraded to free shipping jas.com code
NES k wle s speaking of generational
divides
I posted a Twitter poll yesterday an exp
poll now we call it yesterday was Martin
Luther King day and I didn't even
remember it was Martin Luther King day
until the end of the
day I noticed that there was some anti-
MLK posting going around on social
media MLK had become kind of
controversial and so I just I said hey
do you think Martin Luther King was a
hero as I when I was growing up everyone
thought Martin Luther King was a hero do
you think he was a hero or do you think
he's overrated and I said an answer
according to your age so if you're 44
and over you know pick this button and
if you're under 44 click this button and
I chose 44 because that's the cut off
for Gen X so I wanted to see how the the
Gen X and the Boomers differed from the
Millennials and the Zoomers here and for
genx and the Boomers it was 50/50 which
is actually somewhat surprising to me
50/50 MLK is overrated versus MLK is a a
hero for the younger people on this on
this highly scientific Twitter poll that
you know I just put out there but it got
a zillion votes a lot of people
retweeted
it it was 3
to2
overrated a clear majority of the
younger people responding to that bll
said overrated and that part I believed
I got the sense that younger people are
not as hot on Martin Luther King as
older people why is this is it because
the younger people are more racist or
something no I don't think it's that
exactly is it because they're less
educated no I don't think it's that
exactly I think it's that we are in a a
moment of major political shift and part
of that shift is we're tearing down a
lot of statues and we're upending a lot
of myths and that happens a lot and it
it's happening all over the place we
live in an age where people are tearing
down statues of Christopher Columbus and
George Washington okay and Martin Luther
King is as close to a secular Saint as
there can be he is in the the pantheon
of the liberal secular
deities at least a saint if not an
outright
deity but we're not only going to be
tearing down statues of old white guys
from the 18th century we're going to be
tearing down all of the statues we in a
an age of
debunking that's the word it's kind of a
stupid word but that's the word that is
so popular we're going to debunk
everything we're going to demystify
everything we're going to disenchant
we're going to rip up these myths and
and so the Zoomers who say they they
think MLK is overrated they've got
decent enough reason to I mean there was
the discovery in recent years that the
man was witnessed to a rape and kind of
laughed about it uh that Martin Luther
King
palled around with Communists even if he
wasn't a communist himself that Martin
Luther King though presented as a
Christian Reverend didn't really believe
in the most basic aspects of
Christianity he he denied the Divinity
of Christ he denied the Miracles it was
little complicated plagiarized to PhD
thesis uh which you know now is a a
bigger issue because we just booted the
president of Harvard University for that
uh so yeah those are all the knocks on
him the man also did really great things
though but in the age of debunking in
the D of of demystifying and
disenchanting we ignore the great thing
we ignore the great things George
Washington did we ignore the great
things Lincoln did we're certainly going
to ignore the great things Martin Luther
King did and so that would be the reason
why someone on the right might be a
little skeptical of King and then the
left has hated Martin Luther King for
quite a while now because even though
King was presented for some time as a
leftwing figure now the left is not so
interested and I have a dream that we
won't be judged on the color of our skin
now the left is much more interested in
Malcolm X and they are in Martin Luther
King now rather than seeing Martin
Luther King as a symbol of a a a major
Progressive victory in the
1960s they they see him as an impediment
to to real radical change and the left
now is far more radical than it was 10
20 30 years ago so Martin Luther King's
coming down and and people are going to
be very upset about this I you know I
don't really care one way or the other I
think the man did some great things I
think the man had some problems too and
uh you know when I when I consider
Saints I usually consider Christian
Saints you know like the Saints
canonized by the church I I'm not saying
that secular liberal culture can't
canonize some good people along the way
too it certainly have but it's just not
my primary
focus but but it happens it happens the
great Heroes of one
age they disappear so the question now
is who who are the heroes we're going to
raise up in their place we're in a very
destructive moment
what are we going to build up in in in
their place if anything at all it's
because it's a lot easier to destroy
than it is to build now speaking of
black guys and Christianity little NS X
the rapper who um infamously made a
music video of him getting um violated
by the Devil Himself little nasx uh then
said he was he was becoming Christian
and he was going to go study the Bible
at a Christian College
and he made a big media campaign about
this even though the college said we've
never heard of this guy he's not doing
that then he came out with this
Blasphemous music video very sa
religious video that we covered on the
show briefly and now he's responding to
the backlash against his sacrilege he
says oh you know I I had no idea that
people would be offended I obviously
meant no
offense so first of all when I did the
artwork I knew like there would be some
upset people or whatnot uh simply cuz
you know religion is a very sensitive
topic for a lot of
people but I also didn't a mean to like
mock this wasn't like a you to you
people um you to the Christians like you
know it wasn't it was not that it was
literally me saying oh I'm back I'm back
like Jesus and I will say though with
the communion
video with me eating the crackers and
jeice
I uh I thought that video was going to
be the video to lighten the mood to take
it down like less serious and what not I
thought that was something that we all
wanted to do as kids and whatnot but I
didn't
understand the idea of
um you know the reality of what it is
you know it's me eating the commune
which is like the symbolism of like
Jesus's blood and and bones or something
like that I don't remember completely
but
um I did not mean it to as like a
cannibalism thing or whatever the
freak but I do apologize for that yeah
really sincere doesn't that seem really
sincere I don't know I I always try to
look for the best in people and give
people the benefit of the debt but he's
obviously not sincere at all he's
obviously still trolling oh I'm so
shocked I made this music video right
after I made this video where I was
getting violated by the devil and uh I
made another Another music video where I
put satanic imagery all over the place
incl including in heaven and and
presented myself as Jesus on an upside
down crucifix so satanic image there and
had all sorts of devils in heav it's
just so weird I can't I didn't obviously
didn't mean to offend you no man I I
just didn't know you know and then when
I when I mocked the the Eucharist when I
mocked the Blessed Sacrament I just
didn't know CU I didn't what I didn't
know was like what supposed to symbolize
like like uh Jesus's bones and stuff
bones and stuff I yeah I don't know I
didn't look it up you could have looked
it up before you made the video if you
actually wanted to apologize but he
probably did look I'm sure he looked it
up and he's but he's mocking us he's and
he's mocking more than mocking us as
Christians he's mocking God God is Not
mocked it's not a good thing to do not
not something to be
recommended so okay he keeps strolling
he's going to keep doing it he'll his
next music video will be the same thing
and he'll keep the shtick up as long as
he can and then his foot will slide in
due time and that will be very sad for
him
this is all he can do and more than
little nasx this is all the devil can
do nothing that little nasx has done is
in any way original it's all just
derivative and it's all sa satire and
parody that's all he can do the Black
Mass which is the Satanic ritual is just
a parody of the true Mass all of his
commentary is just is just mocking True
Religion that's all they can do that's
what the devil does the devil just kind
of mocks you the devil just he can tempt
you he can mock you he can he can Vex
you a little
bit but he can't really do anything new
because God is being itself you know
when Moses asks God in the burning bush
says who shall I tell them that you are
God says I am that I am meaning God God
is
being full stop period being and so
uh God is what is really real really
truly real and uh the opponents of God
they're not they're not the opposite you
know it's not like the yin and the Yang
they're just they're they're a privation
of goodness and truth and Beauty they're
a privation of of being they're nothing
just a little carbunkle on the side of
the bark of Peter so he'll he'll keep
keep this up for a while and he'll he'll
keep laughing until he's not laughing
anymore but the one thing he won't do is
have an original idea these guys never
ever do now speaking of religion and
Atheism possibly the most famous atheist
in the world has just
suggested that he might become
religious this would be Richard Dawkins
one of the four horsemen of the new
atheist movement there was Christopher
Hitchens who was wrong about a lot of
things but at least he was entertaining
and so the late Christopher Hitchens
Daniel Dennett was the philosopher of
the bunch uh Sam Harris who's gone a
little bit off the deep end and Richard
Dawkins so Dawkins tweets out maybe
there is still something for me to learn
when it comes to religion my dear friend
and former atheist Ian her Ali has
become a Christian we will be discussing
this at the inaugural dissident
dialogues Festival sign up here wow man
even forget about Dawkins for a second
even Ian her Ali ion her Ali was one of
the big figures of Atheism in the mid
2000s when atheism was really
fashionable when Hitchens was publ and
Dawkins and all those guys were
publishing their books and going on TV
and hosting debates about how religion
is bad and God doesn't exist and they
were making weak arguments but it was a
it was a publishing fad and so they got
a lot of air time and ion hery Ali was
out there too and then ion hery Ali A
few months ago we covered it on the show
she became a
Christian there are a lot of people who
were firm atheists who have at least
weakened in their atheism to the point
of saying okay well I'm agnostic or I
think Christianity is good I just can't
quite believe or I'm a cultural
Christian because I I recognize that
atheism is not sufficient to sustain a
civilization some have gone further like
ion her Al to say no I actively am
Christian now and even Richard Dawkins
the most famous living atheist says
maybe there's something that I still
have to learn when it comes to religion
this is not an age for
atheists atheism is a Lu y of a once in
an Epoch period of peace and material
Prosperity that's when it cropped up at
the very peak of American prosperity and
Global Peace and it was just when that
just at the very tail end of it but we
we we were making so much money and
everything was calm and America was the
unrivaled global
hedgemon and everyone was just kind of
an
atheist and and then Muslim Muslims
attacked the United States and uh
because it was Politically Incorrect to
attack Islam uniquely there was this
final attack on all religion all
Superstition it was all the kind of the
language of the Enlightenment the
language of the the decadent parts of
modernity there all religion is total
nonsense you know but then history kept
going and some of that material
Prosperity was threatened and the peace
has has disappeared and we're now on the
brink of World War three and people
started thinking again about things
other than their their wallets and the
stasis that we'd all been in and the
religious questions keep popping
up people are asking what a man is what
a woman is that's not a question that
you can answer with money that's not a
question that you can answer with
atheism it's a question about about what
it means to be what is there a soul what
is there the activists seem to think
that there is something like a
soul because they say that their
identity is not their body you can't you
need religion to answer that kind of a
question are we going to have a nation
what's the proper relation of a man to
his family and his community and the
whole world what what are our
obligations to foreigners Mass migration
is a big crisis what are our obligations
what what does morality tell us about
you can't you got to engage in those
religious questions again the the old
gods have returned the old pagan gods
have returned the old old weird sex
Cults have returned the and and the so
the only way to fight the old gods
is True
Religion it's the only it's the only way
to do either you just become a pagan
which plenty of people have done or you
return to the true Faith but no religion
is no longer tenable that that time has
passed it's very very mid 2000s very
very dated so maybe Professor Dawkins
will hop on over wouldn't that be great
now speaking of professors there is a
Harvard Professor who has
just given the the most perfectly
liberal take on the entire Public Square
at where else the world economic Forum
where liberal Elites from all over the
world Gather in Davos to decide how to
run our lives we'll get to that in one
second first though you know as a father
I am quite concerned about the kind
messages that my kids are exposed to in
the media that is why I'm thrilled about
Ben key the new kids streaming
Entertainment app from the daily wire
right now you too can check out the
entire world of beny for free for 14
days beny is the only kids streaming app
that you can trust to provide quality
content that aligns with your beliefs
and worldview you won't find any gender
confusion any climate hysteria or social
justice propaganda on Ben key just
premium quality content that kids will
love and parents can trust try bent key
for free for 14 days that is 14 days of
unlimited access to beny's World of
Adventure a world full of Incredible
characters and Timeless stories that
will entertain and Inspire for the Next
Generation use the code unlock at
checkout to get 14 days of free access
to Bent key no strings attached you can
cancel anytime but I'm sure that you
will not want to because once you see
the amazing content that bent key has to
offer you will be hooked don't wait go
to Bent key.com use code unlock at
signup to start your trial today my
favorite comment yesterday is from
Marcus Caba 4079 who says Michael is one
Italian tie away from closing the door
on SLA and insisting she not ask him
about his business I know it's true
because I was wearing my Italian double
breasted Blazer yesterday I said one of
my big New Year's resolutions it's not
necessarily to work out you know or read
more books or do something it it was I
think I need to wear more double
breasted jackets and so we've begun that
and now pretty soon perhaps I will um
murder all of my enemies and move my
family business to Las Vegas we'll see
we'll find
out a Harvard Professor on a panel at
the world economic forum is going off
about the danger posed to society
by Twitter by by conservatives being
able to speak somewhat freely about
anything anywhere for a long time I was
on Twitter um and now it's become such a
toxic place that I've concluded it's not
a worthwhile place to spend time and as
you said it is exhausting so you do have
to pick and choose and you have to think
about where the places where you can get
your message across but I am trying to
figure out I mean I have given up on X
what a scary name that even is right um
and I don't know what the alternative is
right now what is
scary about the name
X Elon responded he said X is just a
letter of the alphabet what what how how
is it
scary this is
proof that the the Liberals will just
present anything they don't like as
scary and they always they say oh this
Trump he's scary those other Republic
some Republicans I might not agree with
them but there but this Trump he's
really scary say first of all Trump is
SC how is Trump scary Trump you you
liked Trump for like 40 years
Trump is scary he was on every tabloid
he was on every talk show he was a he
was a network game show host he had a
very popular clothing line and clubs and
he's the least scary guy in the country
what are you talking about no he's very
scary uh listen I I want a healthy
Republican party but this Trump man he's
scary no you're just saying he's scary
because he's the guy now just like you
were saying Romney was scary just like
you were saying McCain is scary all also
guys that you previously had liked now
you like sort of like like them again
cuz they turned on Trump and you know
okay fine this goes all the way back to
the Goldwater campaign where the libs
trotted out some guy and they said he
said I am I wish I had a clip of the of
the the ad I you know I'm a lifelong
Republican but this Barry Goldwater man
he's scary but they'll do it to anything
they'll do it to the letter X isn't that
a scary letter
what would y have been less would W have
been less scary no it's just anything
anything including the most benign anod
things that we do will be called scary
and so you got to not let that affect
you they're going to say this stuff
about anything that we do and and what's
the substance of X what x is is Twitter
but conservatives are allowed to speak
it's Twitter but conservatives are
probably not going to be banned for
being right-wing and we're probably not
going to be shadowbanned and we can just
speak that's the scary thing it's very
scary very scary to the left
now they're plotting at at Davos how to
control our lives and Implement all
sorts of New U instruments in politics
and corporations and universities to
control us one of the main ways they do
that is through Dei and the CEO of
United Airlines has just promised that
he is going to implement Dei all
throughout his company up to and
including the
cockpit how is diversity and diversity
targets working into the aviat academy
we have committed that 50% of the class
of of the classes will be women or
people of color today only 19% of our
Pilots at United Airlines are women or
people of color and by the way from all
the data I've seen that's the highest of
any airline in the country white males
don't just dominate in the cockpits also
in the sea suite at United Airlines well
look at United I'm proud of the
diversity that we actually have in our
our SE Suite I think if you look around
Corporate America correct me if I'm
saying though so I this was just based
off your website to people people you
list as Executives but out of 11 people
three are women I believe one is a
person of color um that's correct um but
you know in Corporate America I think
you know that's a low bar how do you
raise your own bar well a lot of this is
you know focusing on it we have uh
programs to one of the things we do is
for every job when we do an interview we
require women and people of color to be
involved in in the interview process
bringing people in early in their
careers um as well uh and giving them
those opportunities uh and creating a
stronger
bench
okay I don't care what this man does to
his sea Suite I don't care if he fills
it all with a bunch of lesbian pygmy
Muslim zarrian I don't I don't
care the cockpit worries
me Dei is necessarily opposed to
Quality necessarily because with de says
is we're going to make you use diversity
equity and inclusion standards to
deprioritize Merit when you hire someone
or admit someone to University or bring
someone into your Club we're going to
deprioritize Merit because we're
boosting sex or race or sexual behaviors
or
whatever some liberals have tried to
argue that Dei actually accentuates
quality and Merit that is logically
impossible because the entirety of what
Dei is is saying there are other
considerations that you should place
above Merit or candidate
quality
Dei in restaurants means that you value
diversity more than your dinner okay Dei
in universities means that you value
diversity more than you your education
that's not good that's a little
scary Dei in the cockpit means that you
value diversity more than your life and
I do not I do I don't really
like diversity as the Liberals talk
about it I think it's a pretty dark
thing and not conducive to anyone's
flourishing I think it's just radical
leftist politics and degrading to
everyone I certainly don't don't like it
more than I like my life this is madness
this is actual
suicide Michael are you saying that a
black woman can't fly an airplane I'm
I'm sure some black women can fly
airplanes but I am certain that Dei
policies will lower the candidate
quality of the pilots and I don't want
to get on those planes luckily I don't
really fly United that much so that's
good for me but if you do uh sorry you
know I guess we should all pray that
this turns around because that uh that
won't turn out very
well jelly roll is addressing another
National problem do you know jelly roll
I don't really know who jelly roll is
but he's an interesting sounding guy and
he's got a lot of face
tattoos uh jelly roll's a former drug
dealer and I think he's a musician now
and he has got a line he has got a take
on political problems that is really
really good but because I'm a teas and
I've run out of time I'm going to have
to get to that tomorrow so how do you
like that that's me I'm a tease what can
I say that's our show I'm Michael N this
is the Michael N show we're still snowed
in so I'm still stuck here in my home
I've got the Barbarians at the gates and
my bar barbarians I mean my little
children and so we might be back in the
studio tomorrow I hope we are but we'll
wait and see in any case jelly roll will
have to wait until then I'm Michael no
this the Michael no show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
a